[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a analizar la situación en medio
oriente con el reciente ataque que dejó
al menos 14 personas muertas y 59
heridas ataque se llevados a cabo por la
guardia Revolucionaria iraní contra
grupos curvos en el kurdistán de Irak
supuestamente por su apoyo a las
protestas tras la muerte de maxa Mini
los kurdos son La minoría para poner un
poco de contexto étnica más numerosa sin
estado propio integrada por 30 millones
de personas repartidas principalmente de
Turquía Irán Irak y Siria saludamos
entonces a said chaya él es el director
del núcleo de estudios de medio oriente
de la Universidad austral de Argentina
saí de que bueno tenerlo nuevamente con
nosotros en directo América de Francia
24 la situación de los kurdos porque son
tan perseguidos por varios gobiernos
para poner un contexto y ya pues irnos
metiendo en el tema
bueno sabes que tenemos más de 30
millones de kurdos digamos habitando la
región de medio oriente fundamentalmente
esa triple frontera existente entre
Turquía
Irán y
bueno y vemos que digamos más o menos
hay unos 9 millones de kurdos viviendo
en Irán han aspirado a tener desde la
caída del Imperio otomano más o menos en
1917 1918 a tener un estado propio
diciendo que en la década del 20 en
algún momento tuvieron no un estado de
muy corta vida y bueno desde entonces
están peleando por el reconocimiento de
la Constitución de un estado propio
dentro de fronteras que ya han sido
dibujadas no Y ese es el gran problema
que que que que emerge hoy said nunca
tendrán digamos su territorio su estado
propio Por qué pues está negativa no
Bueno creo que fue difícil digo dibujar
hoy la frontera del medio oriente No ya
son fronteras o estas estas líneas en la
arena como como como se dijo alguna vez
como como fueron configuradas después
del acuerdo sex picot salvo una revisión
posterior en 1923 1924 a pedido del
Estado Turco recientemente creado una
República No no ha habido demasiadas
rectificaciones fronterizas en la región
por lo que implicaría de alguna manera
que Turquía Siria Irán e Irak tendrían
que donar de alguna manera territorios
no de sus respectivos países para que
estas 30 millones de personas tengan
pueda cumplirse no este derecho a un
estado propio yo creo que lo más que lo
más factible a lo que se puede aspirar
creo en el corto plazo es a un estatuto
de autonomía similar al que tiene
justamente en Irak actualmente No creo
la situación en Siria en algún momento
se encaminó a eso después se fue
desdibujando en Turquía la tiene
bastante más complicada en Irán también
pero de pronto un régimen autonómico
como el que como el que pueden disfrutar
en Irak creo que es un escenario posible
dentro de
un tiempo más o menos corto no eso es
algo que se podría lograr claro hablamos
de territorio digamos que todavía no
tienen un estado propio reconocido
digamos no sé internacionalmente pero
ellos sí se regulan y en esos
territorios sí funcionan Digamos como
como un estado propio con como un
ejecutivo de un gobierno Digamos como lo
conocemos nosotros aquí en occidente
Sí es que es que de hecho digamos los
los curos en el caso iraquí que es donde
de pronto están más organizados no
entiendo que tienen además la
posibilidad de administrar los recursos
naturales en
ese territorio del curristan iraquí no
Además bueno esta esta Digamos como
nación tienen su propio idioma sus
costumbres que han logrado no conservar
en el último siglo a pesar de no tener
un estado propio como si la ha pasado al
resto de los Países Árabes de la región
ahora volviendo a lo que vimos ayer
miércoles este ataque por parte de Irán
a este territorio del kurdistán iraquí
Ellos dicen Irán Obviamente que hicieron
este ataque porque supuestamente los
kurdos de Irak estarían detrás de lo que
son las protestas lo que fueron las
protestas porque supuestamente Ya se
acabaron según el gobierno de Irán por
la muerte de maxam Mini realmente
realmente los kurdos podrían estar
detrás de estas protestas digamos no sé
históricamente Ellos se han filtrado de
alguna manera en Irán para tratar de
sabotear al gobierno de la República
islámica Bueno
ya el tiempos del yang Sí hay grupos
revolucionarios en grupos Rebeldes no sé
como como quiera llamarle en la frontera
entre Irán Irak no que se desplazan y
eventualmente realizan ataques contra
poblaciones civiles ataques esporádicos
contra poblaciones civiles etcétera esto
seguimos nueva estrategia
conforme a lo que está diciendo el
gobierno iraní no imagínense que el
acceso a la información que tenemos por
parte de lo que está sucediendo en Irán
es limitado pero en función de lo que
dice el gobierno iraní que lo podemos
poner en duda es que estos grupos ahora
se han infiltrado esto sería una
estrategia nueva por parte de estos
grupos no porque realmente
que habitualmente han hecho es realizar
ataques o atacar posiciones militares en
la frontera cercana con Irak también es
ahí eso sería digamos una estrategia de
gobierno un discurso de gobierno para
poder ir contra ellos también lo vemos
por el lado de Turquía
yo creo que
a mí me parece que hoy Irán está una
solución muy compleja muy compleja a
nivel interno tienen una serie de
problemas
socioeconómicos muy graves en un
contexto en el en el cual esta alianza
que supo existir en tiempos de Home mini
entre el clero y los sectores populares
se ha caído no entonces de alguna manera
en lugar de negociar
poder volver a ese a ese régimen de
poder compartido entre los sectores
populares y el clero lo que han decidido
los aletolás es ir por todo y hemos
visto acá que han por la represión en
lugar de en lugar de el lugar de
encaminar una serie de reformas No creo
que estos ataques tienen que ver más con
la posibilidad de desviar la atención no
porque
de otra manera nos explica
esta esta violencia de los ataques
contra contra las posiciones curvas que
son cuestiones esporádicas creo que el
último incidente fue hace cinco o seis
años y desde entonces no no habíamos
escuchado más este fen